que la lumière soit bien mieux que la
lampe d'aladin les génies du laboratoire
d'ingénierie des systèmes de versailles
de l'université versailles saint quentin
ont imaginé un système permettant de
transférer des informations numériques
via le spectre lumineux par exemple sur
de l'audio vous avez donc un lecteur mp3
un lecteur mp3 presse des données
numériques cdu 0 1
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va
faire communauté ce qu'on appelle
l'éclairage à led
c'est comme si on éteignait on allume et
à des fréquences très rapide ou à des
fréquences variés et du coup bah vous
véhiculez pour ça les informations les
données les héros de l'autre côté vous
avez un photorécepteurs airs transcode
redécollent cette information a pour
transformer sans en une musique c'est
exactement le même principe que sur le
logis avec un avantage
aucune émission d'ondés
électromagnétiques sur cinq ans cinq
cent mille euros ont été investis pour
développer cette technologie peu
onéreuses selon ses concepteurs
les scientifiques de ce laboratoire
travaille désormais au sein d'une start
up destiné à la commercialisation du
produit
une société dont ubs qu pourrait bien
devenir actionnaire côté clients
plusieurs grandes entreprises se sont
déjà montrés intéressés comme la sncf ou
encore philips le nous écrivains de
montréal au québec a déjà fait
l'acquisition pour 4 100 mille euros de
plusieurs tablettes équipées de cette
technologie des lampes seront installés
au dessus des mannequins de cire que
pour l'ancien de repas sera en dessous
un contenu multimédia sera envoyé sur la
paire n'a eu aucune manipulation ne sera
nécessaire
cette technologie est encore en
développement pour l'instant les envois
de données ne fonctionne que dans un
sens
les ingénieurs espèrent bien à long
terme réussir à faire des échanges ce
qui permettrait notamment d'imaginer une
utilisation pour le web
pourquoi pas en lieu et place du wifi